it's not truffles that ondrea's poller
is searching for here in the alpine
forest he's a sorcerer and supplier of
tonewood timber with the right acoustic
properties for making talk calibers
string instruments in this case spruce
the toughest part is translating the
language or the requirements of the
violin maker back into the appropriate
wood you have to find trees that
correspond exactly to what the people
who work with the wood want
being able to see the tone wood for the
trees requires specialist knowledge that
explains why ondrea's parlors customers
travel so far to see him genre we push a
song is a violin maker from France
coming here to Bavaria meant taking a
1000 kilometer trip the violin makers
it's a little crazy about the wood the
wood suppliers have high standards only
one in a hundred trees provide the
necessary quality of tone wood and
Leia's poller comes across his personal
favorite only every five years or so the
timber is left to dry for five years
initially the supplier has to check the
wood on a daily basis over time he can
tell how good the wood is Mert is clean
but it does have a sound but it's still
dull and it decays right away the wood
isn't mature yet it needs more time to
dry but it has the potential to develop
positively
once the wood has dried properly he can
plane it off again as the customer
desires
he might deploy an industrial saw but
this work involves an expert touch all
violin makers have their own quirks and
characteristics just like every piece of
wood it involves all your senses as well
as looking you also have to feel in your
hands how the wood is developing planing
or sawing will give you a good idea how
easily the saw cuts through the wood
whether it's hard or tough you discover
the characteristics of each piece of
wood character you shop from tonight
into its and but there's more to
building a quality instrument than just
the right planks the key to a good tompa
is found in this little rod which has to
be carefully checked this isn't this is
a sound post it gets inserted in a
vertical position the sound post is the
sole of the violin it transfers the
vibrations that constitute the sound no
violin making set is complete without
one two-thirds of the wood on today's
collar supplies ends up abroad his
French visitor spends five hours
checking cello parts
he makes just three of the instruments a
year each with a price tag of 28,000
euros so the wood has to be top-notch
it's good
he spent 2,000 heroes on tonewood for
cello tops bats and finger boards his
next visit won't be for another year
meanwhile ondrea's Paulo will get back
on the trail looking for the next tree
with those prized musical properties